we are thrilled to have back here on the
Rich Eisen show espn.com senior honor
Ramona Shelburne how you doing Ramona oh
man I got finally had to sleep seriously
that's nice
no seriously I kind of like fell asleep
on the couch really early and I like it
was you know I never go to sleep before
midnight they're like this was finally
like the calls stopped like 10:00 p.m.
and I think I just like fell asleep on
the couch and woke up at like 4:00 in
the morning like woah oh man this is it
a heck of a week so far I play this game
with shefter frequently Ramona so let's
do that right now what is let's just put
our journalist hat
put it in there Oh take it off for money
what's the craziest rumor
unsubstantiated rumor that you've heard
that's come across your ears this week
oh ok crazy like crazy crazy show me
yeah ok I think that there are teams
that are already calling New Orleans
trying to get Anthony Davis like I mean
I don't know how the heck you could get
them and that kind of answer like
there's all the people who you think are
untouchable but I think there's I think
there's teams especially the one that I
cover pretty closely the Lakers who have
some designs and how can we get Anthony
Davis year right I mean because we're
all in this like fantasy basketball era
where everyone's trying to construct
these these super teams that can contend
with gold and say because that's really
the only way you can be safe
well I mean I'm starting a show by
saying all my all my Laker fan friends
here in Los Angeles and all the Laker
fans that I I here locally on the radio
Ramona think that Lonzo is going to get
drafted and then Paul George is going to
get acquired and then LeBrons coming so
everything's coming up roses for the
Lakers is we're currently sitting here
in the home three of those players are
not currently on their roster so what
what is the Laker plan right now are
they still trying to wade out George and
draft Lonzo and try and get the cap
space cleared for LeBron at some point
what is there yeah I think I think
that's a plan I mean I think yesterday
was a really big deal just because they
cleared out like the contact for Timofey
Mozgov right and they still have some
work to do because I remember last year
when they signed Mozgov and dang who all
day and it was like I remember it was
like in the first 24 hours of reading
second - one of them was real
I think Mozgov was first off the board
and and what is like the Taj I was 4
years 64 and I had my pick one when GM
hit because they were we was the first
sticker shock contract last year I
remember that was the first one but whoa
I guess this is what people are getting
now right now this is seller cab spike
the one GM was like did the Lakers say
to Mozgov agent like four for 16 and
like they just got it wrong like did
they mean like four years the 16 total
and then it like the agent came back
integrate so 16 a year okay
like that's how bad that contract was
like in terms of value it just kind of
set things in motion you know but very
soon afterwards they signed the wall
dang to a contract that's even worse for
year 72 and so those two contracts were
like I think they were the final nail in
the coffin for you know Jim busts and
Mitch Kupchak in the eyes of their
sister because they were just so
unjustifiable and and they they really
lock the Lakers into this place where
it's like they don't have any way of
getting better unless they can find
someone who would take them and you know
what it took to get rid of one of the
context and the Mozgov contract is the
worse of the two contracts it took
getting into trading the guy who was the
number two overall pick in the draft two
years ago and I know D'Angelo wasn't you
know didn't top and it's for a couple
years right and he wasn't but I don't
think he had gotten to bust at if I
think he had a he had a year last year
you saw some potential you're like okay
if you put some in the right spot and
you figure out how to use in the right
way he matured a lot last year like you
know you even still I can in the growth
process where you say this is absolutely
selling low on him but that's what it
took to get rid of the Mozgov contract
and if they're able to turn that salary
cap space into two superstar players
it'll be worth it if they're not well
that's step that's the the risks are
taking now but I feel more confident Rob
palinka and Magic Johnson as being able
to do that than I do in gym busting
Mitch Kupchak well I mean when it all
comes down to it though you think okay
let's slot Lonzo ball in their second
overall and then use the cap space but
then there are reports that the number
two overall pick might be used to lure
Paul George right here right now and
start the process right now it did the
Lakers have to sacrifice one for the
other do you think I don't think so I
think if it you know look that's a
leverage point right now okay that
Indiana was number two fake because
quite frankly if you're Indiana like
Paul George put you in a very
uncomfortable position where you really
have no leverage I mean because they've
made because this is now public and
because you know he clearly wants to go
to Lakers like any team that's training
for him is going to do it as a rental
and it's that's really hard to give up
good young players and takes and assets
and all you know it's really hard to
justify doing that for guy who's going
to leave right and and not to mention
how uncomfortable before that guy in
your town all year like that questions
all year long like well you're just
going to the lake so it almost made it
so that Indiana can only deal with the
Lakers and and you know that's why they
were talking yesterday from what I
understand like Indy just you know they
never moved off wanting that to pick and
you know the to the to construction I
had heard was one was like a to pick and
D'Angelo and then there was another one
that was the Angelo and Brandon Ingram
so it was you know they think there's
two assets the Lakers don't want to move
in over to pick or Brandon and they
Indies still asking for them for Paul
Jordan I think you know sometimes it's
about winning the press conference right
you know we were talked about all the
time if you're indie and you've been
backed into this position by the player
and he wants to go to LA you can't then
trade him to the place that he wants to
go and have a deal that seems like you
lost remote a shelburne of ESPN joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show and yet
when you're sitting here in Los Angeles
trying to lure LeBron up having a point
guard in Chris Paul
and then having a grocery shopper in the
form of the guy that LeBron is referred
to as the Godfather and Jerry West it
would be helpful to have that all in one
place and there is one place that
actually does have that all in one place
is we're currently sitting here in the
Clippers what do you think the Clippers
are going to do over the next couple of
days here Ramona I don't think is what
the Clippers can do they're so boxed in
you know there's
with their salary tab situation like if
they resign Chris Paul and Blake Griffin
I mean I just the only option they
really have is to trade DeAndre Jordan
or the Austin Rivers and I don't know
how much you get for Austin Rivers
DeAndre would get a lot but again he's a
free agent after one more year and we
remember how free agency went for him
the last time so you know I think I
think that's a that I see matters and
factors into teams that would
potentially trade for somebody so this
is all so much they could do they're
kind of they kind of are what they are
and the only way that they substantially
changes if they let their players go and
if they let their players go then you go
okay well what are you going to get for
them I'm going to do a sign-and-trade or
you you know can you get anything back
or are you just really starting over I
don't know I don't think they have many
moves as much as Jerry wes is an
incredible architect and he's still a
great eye for talent you know i they
needed him two years ago you know they
really needed him two years ago because
they've they've wasted a lot of
first-round picks they've been you know
reckless in the way that they've drafted
and traded away those six and that's
what Jerry's best at and so now they're
in a spot where like they you know you
needed it two years ago that I don't
know how much he's really going to be
able to do with what they have is
they're kind of you got Blake and
Christy Andre and that's about it and
like maybe if Yuri sign them then you
can you can trade one of them in
February or something and reconstitute
the team but it's like it's just it's
just not a it's just they're really
locked in there you know it's like a
country with that that's not near the
ocean they're landlocked
where do you go you know a couple more
minutes left with NBA and solder and
senior writer from ESPN Ramona Shelburne
so here we are 24 hours before the draft
and the DeAngelo Russell trade makes
everybody think it's going to be Lonzo
ball
what is the Lakers thoughts on balls dad
Lavar now that is finally push come to
shove time yeah with 24 hours to go and
is it possible we get the biggest
surprise of the draft with the air and
Fox's name being mentioned second
overall come on I mean like look I'll
tell you like I I don't think they've
been concerned about Lavar balls just in
the sense that you know one he's
from him lately have you noticed that he
hasn't been public in the last couple
weeks
why not oh not only that Ramona we saw a
hilarious footlocker a lot where where
Lonzo is poking fun of the situation you
know a little bit of humility and sense
of humor in a manner that we haven't
seen it
yeah and that nice letter he wrote on
players to view so they're they're kind
of doing all the right things right now
and I I think some of Lavar ball is like
it's like sort of more us than him in
the way like we keep giving them a
microphone right you know I mean you
keep saying stuff if you put a
microphone in his face so some of it is
just a discipline on their end to say no
so I think that's what would happen in
the last couple weeks and I'll and that
that shows a little self-awareness okay
but I also think that you the concern
with levar and it's not just the Lakers
concerned it's just if he says something
about teammates or future for you know
guys in the league like you know he said
something about teammates gonna be tough
you know you know it's one thing to say
that about TJ leaf at UCLA and like I
don't think TJ appreciate what he said
about him but you know he's a college
kid whatever you went and said that
about a grown man in the NBA who's been
a veteran player like it's not gonna go
over well right I know it didn't go over
well and he was calling up Steph Curry
and LeBron and like but you know you saw
LeBron even respond the fact that he
even dignified that it was totally how
much that bothered him so I think that's
the concern with levar it's not about
anything else about the big ball or
brand or anything I can do what every
wants to do that but it's more about you
saying things about either your
teammates or the guys the league I don't
think it's the reason the Lakers win
drafts and I don't think that factors in
at all the kid can play so and they like
the way you plays they like they think
he makes everyone better the real
question is you know what do you need
more offensive defense because the
Lakers had the absolute worst defense
Maleek last year and Josh Jackson and
here in Fox are huge upgrades they're
not just physically and athletically but
attitude wise and I think I think that's
really what's going back and forth in
their head right now although saying all
this if they keep the toothpick I really
do think you're going to take Lonzo but
if they trade back you know and get an
extra pick somewhere I could see them
take one of those two guys or and or
they like a couple guys later in the
lottery - and so who did the Celtics
take do they take a kid who is medical
it's just finally landed on their desk
just today in John Jackson Ramona yeah I
think that's interesting with Josh
because you haven't come in there to
work out right and you know they're dead
they're really bagging to get those
medical reports and it's just like it's
an interesting way to start a
relationship with a team right and see
especially team like boss and that's a
proud franchise and you know so the one
thing to do that to like you know I'll
pick a small market scene but players
don't like Cleveland or something now I
guess they wouldn't do that to Cleveland
but Charlotte or something to do it to a
team like that but this is a Celtics
that's harder but I think they probably
do pick him anyway just because he's a
great prospect and and he is the most
valued Danny and probably is gonna draft
a kid who has the most value at that
spot and if you know if they don't take
him maybe they take Jason Tatum those
are the two names that said everybody
keeps thinking for the Celtics and what
I love about Boston's position right now
is they went from being the team in the
driver seat where like everybody has to
call them you know to move up or to set
the draft see what they're going to do I
still think they're there I really do I
think there's a lot of teams I want to
trade in to that three spot to have a
shot at Josh Jackson or deer and Fox and
that's you know Danny is the way I do
and you know he's going to use that so
then as for Mona the poll question
before we let her go Brockman yeah
Ramona which team helped themselves the
most this week with their moves the
Sixers the Celtics or the Lakers what do
you think I'm going to say the Sixers
I like the sixes uh I like the big kind
of way they like it they really needed a
guy like that they really need to pull
like a playmaker like that and I know
they gave up a lot but they have so many
drastic like at some point you know you
just got to move and like the whole
point of this was to get starred so the
one guy in this draft that people feel
like could be a star and sooner rather
than later as mark-up fault plays I'll
go with those guys Ramona great work
love having you on next time it's in
studio okay no more phone conversations
for all right there I will work on that
you got it though all right thank you
got it that's Ramona Shelburne of ESPN
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
so Rich Eisen shown weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country
and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy